did you know that the world has almost
eight times more debt than it has money
global debt reached 281 trillion dollars
in 2021
but there's only around 37 trillion
dollars in circulation how can we owe
more money than there is money in
existence
if i lend you 10 you're 10 in debt and
you have 10 cash
if you lend that same ten dollars to a
friend you created twenty dollars of
debt but there's still only ten dollars
available global debt is all the money
owed by all the people businesses and
governments in the world
that means almost ninety percent of the
money out there isn't real it's fake
money fake money that's made through all
this debt we talked about earlier
debt is based on people believing that
they're gonna make more money back in
the future than they're borrowing right
now it's like using a credit card the
bank knows you don't have the money to
pay it back now but in a few months time
based on your salary they're pretty sure
you will
the money in your credit card doesn't
even exist until you use it it's just a
number on the computer
screen all this fake money is created
every time you buy something the whole
point of all this fake money is to let
people and countries spend more money
than they have right now
in the hopes that they'll use that money
to make more money more innovation in
the future now whether or not people
uses that to make the world more
productive or just blow it on things
like vacations or meme stocks is another
story